[Music]
location
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
where's the bridge
no no no no oh
well that was new
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
very natural but of course i am
all right let's see what that beast is
made of you ready all
crank it if we can't break through we
stop it
[Music]
now
let's see
huh
all of us
the world has a way of changing
and we change too i know some people
there are moments that separate us
but we always come back together
we heard y'all needed a little love out
here
y'all ever thought about the wild
missions we've been on we've taken out
planes
trains tanks i'm not going to think
about the submarine
[Music]
and now we got cars flying in the air
[Music]
who is he jacob is
dom's brother
been a long time dog little brother
you always say never turn your back on
family but you turn your back on me
now your little family is in my world
[Music]
are you ready whatever's on you is you
ready
[Music]
fast
okay this is a bad time to mention this
but i don't drive
brother against brother this should be
interesting
but could you kill him
crank it all the way up get back with
the soldiers
man we messing with magnets now if you
woke the weights up
whoa
it's good to be back we got no white
flag
it's been my entire life in your shadow
and now
you spend the rest of yours
you acting like we on our way to home
depot
i don't want to die
oh [ __ ] it's getting serious
ben diesel reached out and he was
talking about a role
i'm like it's freaking fast and furious
get me there put me on a plane
i like the fact that it's like i'm
representing such a powerful strong
woman
all this crew this is mine she's just
that [ __ ]
yeah i hate saying that
because you know i don't really flirt
with spanish
i remember when i saw ludacris and fast
and furious when i saw tego calderon
then to see don omar it makes the hood
have hope
being around vince he's just so nice so
dope he makes you feel so comfortable
and i'm just so excited elise is such a
badass
[Music]
i got a little tricks on my sleeves for
you
[Music]
i live my life a quarter mile at a time
[Music]
fasten the theories the film so
accurately depicts this world
we haven't seen this culture on film
it's a cool world
i would love to be a part of it for a
long time with this cast
it's really eclectic in terms of
everyone having their own quality to
bring
to it all right all right all right
the most important thing in life will
always be the people in this room
[Music]
right now
[Music]
and just don't give up either absolutely
familiar
life is good it's fast now the things
that happen in this film
are just like okay wait a minute this is
a game changer for sure
fox fans realized early on that we were
willing to defy
expectations with every single chapter
even without you have
no idea i feel so excited for the world
to see
the ninth chapter
[Music]
you